to solve this exercise first don't want
to check out the most recent commit
again using the commit ID that I noted
down this is in the instructors notes in
case you forgot it then I'll do a git
log and I want to check out each of
these commits one at a time until I find
the one with the bug if I do that I'll
find that this commit has the bug and
the previous commit that's not that
means that the commit starting with two
5eg is the one that introduced the bug
and this commit ID is the answer to the
quiz if we want to know exactly how the
bug got introduced we can use git diff
to compare the commits I'll do that now
so git diff then the first commit ID
then the second as you can see in
addition to some other changes this
commit removed the line delay before
bullet equals 10 it's not surprising
that this removal would cause the
problem we saw my guess is that the line
was removed accidentally while making
these other changes